so let's take a look at our latest  numbers now across the state our  positivity rate continues to drop we're  hovering now just around  seven percent that's a huge improvement  also across the state we've had more  than 295  000 cases that since the pandemic  started and more than 5  thousand people have now died governor  steve siselek spoke about that grim  milestone earlier today  and shared how the state will honor the  lives lost he's asked that all flags at  the state capitol  and state public buildings be flown at  half staff  and he recently honored victims in a  candlelight vigil at the governor's  mansion  the lighting of the candles symbolizes  the spirits that will continue  to live on and continue to give us hope  among the darkness  the governor asking all of us here in  nevada to join him in remembrance later  tonight  in either a moment of silence or by  lighting a candle  to help honor those victims